okay I've got a major story to talk to
you about here about something that is
not good that is going on remember last
week when I told you that all right
troll Mike Serna vich started a campaign
to get friend of the show Sam cedar host
of the majority report a voice actor on
Bob's Burgers formerly of air America
radio formerly of one episode of Sex in
the City anyway we all know Sam cedar at
this point he tweeted about Roman
Polanski about eight years ago that
tweet was taken out of context to make
it seem as though he was sort of
minimizing the horrible actions called
sexual assault by Roman Polanski Mike
Serna Mitch this alt-right troll with a
pretty big online following started a
campaign basically to get Sam cedar
fired from MSNBC and to have his
advertisers pull money from his program
he got fired from MSNBC did Sam cedar
until eventually MSNBC realized that
they had sort of not considered the
cynical objectives of Serna vich and his
cronies and MSNBC said they would be
reinstating Sam cedar that's a good
thing now the problem is that in
defending Sam cedar on the David Pakman
show I inadvertently got myself on the
radar of Mike Serna vich and he now has
created a similar online stink which is
leading to hundreds of emails to Boston
College where I am an adjunct professor
demanding that I be fired for an
offensive tweet I'm going to show you
the tweet I am NOT going to be deleting
the tweet it is up on my account I
tweeted last night what I thought was a
pretty clever tweet which was after the
results are in tonight the voters of
Alabama are going to have to reckon with
the reality that win or lose they live
in Alabama now when you look at that
you'll see that there are something like
close to 2000 or even more responses to
this a couple hundred retweets this
tweet got a lot of activity and the
reason that it got a lot of activity is
that Mike Serna vich or more likely
someone told him about it and then he
tweeted about it decided to go after me
for this tweet first Mike's turn of its
retweeted it then he actually
screenshotted it and commented saying is
this what the media
thinks about Alabama first of all the
idea that a tweet from me
is a tweet that could in any way
represent quote the media is laughable
right I host a small independent show in
what way does anything I say reflect
what the media thinks about any issue
this is a sign that we made it maybe
right it's almost flattering and how
outrageous it is but most importantly of
course my tweet is referring to the fact
that Alabamans have been raped and
pillaged by Republicans for decades and
I made that clear in a follow-up tweet
there was a recent UN investigation that
says Alabama has the worst poverty of
the developed world it's a total
disaster and I clarified that in a tweet
where I said this is a criticism of how
Republicans have failed Alabama
education health care public
infrastructure it is not a criticism of
the people although there will be plenty
to criticize about the people who vote
for Roy Moore doesn't matter though
Serna vich has followers after failing
to get Sam cedar fired from MSNBC are
trying to give me the same treatment
they are after me they are sending
tweets to Boston College where I am an
adjunct professor of communications they
are sending emails to Boston College and
I actually I didn't know what to do
because now I'm the target of what I was
just trying to talk about last week when
it came to Sam cedar I reached out to
Boston College this morning and I
explained listen this is who Mike Serna
vich is before you hear about this from
anybody else I want to let you know
about what's going on just so you're
aware of the full scope of my tweets who
this guy is what happened to Sam cedar
etc that aside and hopefully I won't get
fired from Boston College it is
endlessly funny to me how the people who
claim that there's oppressive political
correctness and limits on free speech
and no one has a sense of humor anymore
and they're against safe spaces they are
apoplectic lis playing the outrage card
here they are just outraged because I
made a joke where they misinterpreted
that what I'm doing is making fun of
people in Alabama which if that's what I
was doing it's not really that offensive
I mean it's a pretty mild joke and of
course what I was really doing is
criticizing the politics of Alabama
which are absolutely atrocious I mean
what a snowflake - right and that this
guy has failed
over and over again yeah whether it be
the pizza gate conspiracy that
completely collapsed trying to get Sam
cedar fired actually went on Alex Jones
a show a couple times oh it was a
disaster able performance horrible
before if you haven't seen sir Nova John
Alex Jones check that out yeah I think
that maybe there's some element of Serna
vich being really angry that he didn't
succeed at getting Sam fired I don't
know I mean so far not knock on lucite
I've not yet been fired by Boston
College I picked up thousands of new
Twitter followers as a result because
this got so much attention and by the
way the degree of anti-semitic pond scum
that started coming after me after Serna
[ __ ] SiC them on me last night is
really really stunning
yeah but not surprising not surprising
at all no and finally I feel bad for the
people of Alabama in Massachusetts we
are somewhat protected from the horrible
things that the current federal
administration the Trump administration
is doing we're still going to suffer if
Trump gets his way on all fronts but I
really feel bad for people like in
Indiana where I where I recently was an
economically ravaged State that is only
going to be further crushed by the Trump
agenda Alabama is another example I
actually feel bad the last thing I'm
doing is making fun of the people of
Alabama I am really feeling bad that
they are being crushed by the agendas of
politicians like Donald Trump that's
what's going on I will let you know if
this becomes a firing from Boston
College you can discuss this with us on
reddit at david pakman.com slash re d di
t